the comrades can't have had much time to
unpack their bags from the latest Jazz
Fest that was the Labour Party
conference before they reverted to six
forms Student Union debating society
type the latest reported wheeze to woo
voters this proposed a four day working
week but with your pay untouched it will
be like asking school children if they
vote to abolish homework utter labour
la-la-land drivel and to support this
Marxist madness supporters of a shorter
week point to countries such as France
and Germany where some industries have
boosted output with this plan but that
ignores the crucial fact that Britain
has hordes of SMEs that small and medium
sized enterprises Napoleon was right we
are a nation of shopkeepers and we
should be damn proud of it too in most
instances they simply couldn't afford
this now we all know labour is two
economic reality one Strictly Come
Dancing is to fertility not work whether
over four days or five one of the most
popular self-help books for the last
decade has been called the for our
actually this is a very grueling that
Labour proposing first of all it's not a
policy it's an idea it's an idea I like
you know while I'm I don't feel that I
have the authority to say that it would
work for all industries to have a
four-day workweek what I welcome about
this is the fact that our lives our work
lives have changed dramatically in the
last decade tech has meant that we all
take our work home with us apparently
there are estimates we spend seven hours
a week more working because of our
ability to stay connected at home now
and no political party has taken
ownership of this issue and said what
has this done to our productivity to our
anxiety levels to our relationship with
our children to our ability to care for
our older parents all of these big
social issues that relate to our ability
to have time for our communities and
families have just not been looked at so
I think that actually it's easy to laugh
at you know in call it marks as madness
but I think that there is a serious
issue underlying it which is what will
our work lives be like in the future and
how can we get there while avoiding some
of the huge pitfalls we have now because
there's no question
we're not a happy country suicide we had
mental health a World Mental Health Day
this week suicide is the biggest cause
of death among young men in this country
children levels of anxiety and actually
you know we all talk about children
being on their smartphones too much most
children say their biggest problem is
their parents being on their devices too
much I saw it June reacting quite
vociferous I sort of thought
respectfully I sort of thought you
wouldn't I think I know which way Rachel
and Carol will go I didn't think of it
I'm really intrigued as to which way
you're going to go with my idea or my
opposition to the idea well you're not
gonna believe this Nick but I completely
agree with you
[Laughter]
so at the moment so Andy Haldane from
the Bank of England was talking about
this earlier this week where he was
saying that there's the productivity
puzzle and our productivity levels have
slumped literally for the past decade
now I think the problem isn't that we're
working too long I think the problem is
we're not working long enough I think we
need to increase it instead of five days
Yugi thinks they work weeks look at
what's happened to France haven't work
for them at all so what we need to do is
increase it so here what John McDonnell
says we work the longest hours in Europe
and we yet we're less productive we the
Germans have French producing for days
what we produce in five and yet we've
worked the longest now so the tea you
see say go for it it's labor go I think
we'll be exploring a whole range of
issues about automation in particular
and then how that and we might see that
the working week because I think people
are working too long so that could be in
the manifesto see how it goes and just
to pick up on what John McDonnell was
saying there these are the average
weekly hours we work in the UK higher
than Germany and France but if you look
at our productivity it's significantly
lower than Germany in front so the idea
that the more you work June and if you
work even more you're more productive
it's just proven prevalent I think the
way to solve that is to impose
a cut of 20% on on people's working week
that's not gonna make a more but but my
part you were talking before about first
of all you said something about you it's
not policy it's an idea it will become
policy of the idea caught on but but
there are lots of people in this country
who are already working 40-hour weeks
not the kind of people you describe not
the kind of people who take worker more
involved in the tech whatever people who
are working in factories and warehouses
and all the rest of it 40 hours a week
isn't enough for them they have to get a
second job to go out and actually look
after their families and and and you
know feed their kids so yeah this is the
most ridiculous and it's typical of a
Labour government that just spews out
rubbish with no idea how it's gonna pay
let me just say one thing
yeah they're there they're late the
latest raft of policies you know that
they haven't costed but other people
have and this half a trillion pounds
over the next ten years what's gonna
cost every working family three and a
half
what's the trillion pounds their
policies well if we have a four-day you
know the ridiculous policies that have
been bashful you're too young but if
you're in your mid forties you will have
remember three days where the television
window there are only three television
channels they went off at 10:30 the pub
suppose in 11 the shops pose on Thursday
afternoon we read by candlelight given
that it's never going to happen I'm
prepared to entertain you know comically
that the notion of a four-day week
because you know basically a lot of
employers anyways been you know are gone
and no I mean for days why not I mean if
it if honestly people are going to be
made but I genuinely think that it has
to be down to the employees we can't
have a status do released occur before
day we feel that been four times your
work
Francis O'Grady remember T you see
complicated now as ever
we demand fair shares that means higher
wages less time at work more time with
our loved ones so for the 21st century
let's lift our ambition again I believe
that in this century we can win a
four-day working week with decent pay
for everyone since I love me it's like a
letter to father Christmas I want
everything in the past workers didn't
have five-day working weeks or protected
sickness in holiday was trade in the
past we did not have competition from
India China and the other BRIC countries
we have not got it like that if we will
need to crack its productivity that's
the bit if if you could prove to me that
working seven days a week would increase
our productivity and our viability as a
society I'd go for it but the evidence
is the opposite we've got low
productivity evidence I analyzed your
mental health we bring in automation
actually we will increase productivity
and now you're home well that'll be at
home but we'll be working from home
we'll be doing by loved ones don't want
to see me does work so we have got you
like the sort of lunacy or if it was
reality the key is that for the SMEs if
you're running a massive oil come if
you're running a through the
communication I'm not if you've got half
a dozen people making I don't know a
fact apart in favor of a dick that
forces companies to pay that stuff more
to work for days but there are some
companies that have voluntarily done it
because they actually believe it would
reduce results for productivity and I
also wanted to get you and Vincent
things I had you know you were talking
about the past I don't remember I won't
talk about the future you don't
I'm when there's talked already about
what will humans do when our work is no
longer required for economic
productivity and work will be done by
machines well we all know that we train
people up school people in different
ways and actually the machines will add
to our productivity